-I don't know -- I don't know
how you do it.
But you just wrapped
"Better Call Saul"
and you already filmed
a whole new other series.
-Whoa! One series?
I actually -- Two.
-What? I didn't --
-You know, there's anot--
-I didn't know you had
another show.
-Well, yeah.
This -- I joined the cast of
"Blippi" this season.
[ Laughter ]
-The -- The children's show,
"Blippi"?
-Did you write that?
-No.
-Well, I play Blippi's
evil nemesis, Gorpi.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't even know
Blippi had a nemesis.
I mean, what's going
on the show?
-Just a lot of Blippi stuff,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, basically -- I guess
I should say spoiler alert.
But my character, Gorpi, stole
Blippi's magic strawberry
that teaches him the alphabet.
-Wow.
-And now Blippi can't speak
because he forgot the alphabet.
So that means he can't RSVP to
Mr. Toothbrush's cleanup party.
But what Blippi doesn't know,
right,
is that I've kidnapped his date
to the cleanup party,
Mavis Manners.
And this is throwing the
entire world into turmoil
because now -- and you guys --
you already know this.
But anyway, no one knows how to
say "please and thank you."
Also, just this entire season is
a dream that the number eight
is having.
-Well, this is --
It's interesting.
I wouldn't think that you would
do a children's show.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I mean, they paid me
a lot of money.
[ Laughter ]
Plus, they gave me complete
creative control.
You know what? They even let me
write my own dialogue.
I brought a clip if you guys
want to --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can we do that?
-Let's go.
Can we see it?
-Rick, can we see it?
-Can we see it?
Is there any way to see it?
Do you have any TVs?
-Bob Odenkirk as the villain
Gorpi in the new season of
"Blippi."
-It's happening.
-♪ So much to learn about ♪
♪ It'll make you want to shout ♪
-♪ Blippi ♪
-Alright, listen up,
you pieces of [bleep].
Basically, [bleep]!
Blippi just met a talking crayon
that taught him how to tie
his [bleep] shoes.
You're the only three letters
I trust.
A, Q, Z.
Here's what we're going to do.
A, I want you to break into
Professor Naptime's treehouse.
Steal that [bleep]
finger paints.
Z, I need you to put down
the apple slices and [bleep] up
Barry Broccoli at lunchtime
when he's singing
his healthy lunch song.
Make it look like an "accident."
And, Q, I need to you find out
when Blippi is taking his
next bubble bath because I'm
going to teach
that mother[bleep] a little
something about electricity.
[ Laughs maniacally ]
-Blippi!
-Wow!
Wow, Bob Odenkirk --
-I've just been working.
I've just been working.
-Yeah, I'm so happy.
Congratulations. Bob Odenkirk.
"Lucky Hank" premieres
this Sunday on AMC and AMC+.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.